okay you might have noticed we are not
in the kingside diner right now it's
been kind of a strange day the cameras
gonna die the computer didn't save some
of my files I'm sitting down might come
or better watch out because now origins
given me KitKat's all in all it's just
been a kind of a weird strange day but
nevertheless we're going to get going
and tonight we're going to look at the
reuleaux PES and in particular the
chigorin variation which that's what you
guys wanted to see on youtube so here it
is I got that for you the brayer also
came in a very close second so hopefully
within the next couple months or so
we'll get to go over that as well it's
been suggested that maybe we just do
like a whole month and just do all the
real o PES variations that are relevant
but I think that's kind of unfair
especially with the tournament that's
going to happen like tonight that you
know if you just play the real Lopez
there can be a huge advantage in that
situation but okay we'll get it going
today we haven't talked about this
opening before so all right one of the
most common ways to play after E 4 E 5
and black is usually using this approach
as one of the best ways to equalize it's
one of the most popular moves and the
most common way to defend the pond is
with a knight and we've talked a little
bit about D for the Scotch in the past
this has been covered in some other
videos on the channel so today we're
going to look at the most popular move
which is Bishop to b5 and it probably
looks at first like the idea is okay
we're just going to take this and then
we went upon so you might be thinking
Black has to do something but usually
that pawn isn't unfreeze or early
normally it's it's something you have to
wait for and set up and we'll explain
why but first we'll go over another very
popular variation which is Knight to f6
and this will usually lead to an open
royal Lopez as opposed to the closed
systems that we're going to see today
for example very popular at the top
level right now is the Berlin and they
reach this end game which after the
Queens are traded you see this all the
time and some people
different opinions about this opening
some people you know get kind of excited
they say well there's a lot of rich
middle game plans in this position and
they really like watching them and other
people when they're watching you know
some big tournament they go up another
Berlin ending this is going to be boring
so very mixed opinions on it but it's an
interesting way to play so notice that
the majority on the kingside is going to
be a lot easier for white to in the
future and make a queen then the double
ponds over here so that's one advantage
black can't castle it's true but you
know okay he's got the two bishops and
he can hope for some active play and
okay it's a it's a completely different
opening but I bring it up mostly to
mention the fact that in this position
when the night goes to d6 in lines like
this the bishop is attacked and that'll
be important in a second because we'll
look at lines where black plays a6 and
after the bishop retreats well now if
there's a knight here it's not going to
go to d6 with tempo which makes these
positions a little bit different and
perhaps you're asking okay so why can't
I just take this Knight and then I'm
going to take this pawn so we have
talked about this recently but can
somebody tell me what a black would play
in this position
they just blender up on Arjun Queen d4
excellent a double attack so usually
they save their Knight and they take
here so again it gives me what happens
on what Queen g5 okay so yeah you are
attacking me here huh and you're on my
my knight so this is interesting I know
I assumed I'm just going to like protect
this and if you take here I can play
this move okay it's not the only way to
play but all right I got the center and
if Queens are traded I'm not going to
get checkmated so the fact that I lost
my Jeep on shouldn't be a huge deal but
okay but yeah that's that is interesting
okay but yeah here's the the main point
and I get to once again mention a game
that was played here at the club where
the very suspicious move
[ __ ] was played that was in a
night's game the computer won't let me
do it but the guy that did it was 1500s
so he knew how to do it he castled and
his opponent was 1300 so he didn't know
the castling rule either so very strange
the people so high rated one know that
move is illegal and okay after like some
moves like this it becomes clear at some
point that you know okay this isn't you
know a huge way for white to try to get
an advantage out of the opening so this
can happen now you can play the exchange
the exchange variation is fine but in
this position you should just castle or
you could play d3 Knight c3 or something
but ok castling is the main move you
know you don't just take the pawn ok but
tonight we're going to focus on lines
with a6 and we're going to keep our
Bishop okay so if in the future we might
be threatening to take the knight and
then grab the e pawn so that's something
that we're going to work towards
if this pawn were defended let's say
then we would be threatening to take the
knight and then take the pawn so we'll
see this okay the most common move here
is Knight f6 attacking the pawn and here
white usually castles now you can again
take the pawn but that's not what we're
going to look at today today we're going
to be focused on Bishop to e7
but after Knight takes e4 lines with
rook e1 are possible but a little bit
more critical is d4 and we'll just show
the main variation briefly here since 99
to d6 doesn't attack the bishop you have
to break this pin with a pawn and now
you take and you take with a pawn
not the knight because if you take with
the knight he gets to trade this knight
that's a little bit awkward it's in
front of the C pawn so he doesn't want
to trade that and you get a position
like this and over the next couple moves
White will probably you know shore up
the d4 square make sure that's protected
so black can never advance he's just
going to bring his knight out and just
queen out and he's going to put a lot of
pressure on e4 so what should get a
pretty pleasant position but it's it's
playable and good people have played it
before but we're going to focus tonight
on Bishop to e7 and blacks intention is
just a castle it might seem a little
strange because
in the future you're going to play d6
why would you you know box in your own
Bishop well in a lot of lines we are
trying to take here and it's nice to
have something that's shielding this
file so that if there's ever a rook that
ends up on the e-file black might be
able to get away with a little bit more
because there's something in the way but
all right so here we defend and at last
we are finally threatening to take this
and grab this guy because now the pawn
is defended so blacks got to do
something about that so b5 and okay one
of the big things is is the pawn
especially on b5 is that going to be a
strength or a weakness is black can get
a lot of counter play over there
sometimes it becomes a liability this
pawn so we'll see that in a lot of games
that can end up being weak especially
after some positional move like a4 and
taking and trying to make this pawn
weaker you have a you know I'll fish up
in a queen that can attack it and we'll
see some of those themes today well its
main sources a counter play in this
opening are b5 + e5 so we'll see that
okay now d6 we will take a look at
castling which can lead to some really
exciting stuff like the marshall gambit
so we're going to take a look at that
when we see our first game but okay
we're going to focus on d6 immediately
this is the the close drew Lopez and
White's intention over the next few
moves is to establish a big pond center
that's the one thing that he can argue
as to his big advantage he can get both
of his pawns to the center whereas black
only got one and it's unlikely that
he'll play d5 in the near future
so also Black's about to go take this
bishop which is why c3 makes sense for
both reasons now if you attack our
Bishop we have a retreat Square and okay
it might seem strange that you want to
put your Bishop on such a silly square
but Rui Lopez is going to be a slow
positional maneuvering game or it's
going to be important to keep those
bishops for later on so okay castles and
as a prerequisite for d4 White normally
and search the move h3 which prevents
Bishop to g4 the reason is if you just
play d4 right away that allows Bishop to
for and some good people have played
this variation so I mean I it's not
wrong in any way but black does usually
end up getting a lot of counter play
which is why this variation is unpopular
for example after some normal moves here
black will end up in a position where he
can play either Knight to c4 or c5 and
he tends to get a lot of counter play in
these lines which is why it's typically
avoided and what's a big thing in this
opening is usually he's just trying to
make sure black has no counter play
he'll be a little bit better in the
center and over the course of the game
in the long run he's going to be
squeezing black to death okay
after h3 there's a ton of moves here
today we're going to look at Knight to
a5 but also very common and hopefully we
get to do a video on it soon enough is a
the brayer and okay black removes his at
night he goes backwards which is kind of
funny but he's going to play Knight to
d7 typically he'll reorganize his pieces
and he may or may not play c5 when he
plays as we're going to see in the game
he's kind of committed to a strategy
with c5 which is fine okay we don't want
to lose our Bishop so let's move it out
of the way and okay c5 it's we could
mention too there is a gambit line here
this is the guy you've ski gambit which
is not very popular but it's worth just
taking a quick peek at it to see it's
very similar to the marshal which we'll
have a look at but here it's you know
it's a little bit different the main
line is d4 and it's not the focus of our
lecture so you can examine all the
different captures here for yourself but
the main line is to take and we grabbed
on e5 and white skull is over time he's
going to go and he's going to try that
when round up this pawn and usually that
happens but black can play very actively
and try to get a lot of piece activity
so we'll look at sort of the main line
here he is going to put all of his
pieces to attack this pawn the Queen is
going to be one which will add a third
attacker and white will ultimately be
able to round up the pawn but black is
to cause them a little bit of
disturbance here the only move you can
really play is Knight to g4 and after
this capture you are going to end up
winning this pawn
you can see that black has a lot of
activity he's trying to say for the pond
you know he might be able to bring a
rook into the attack perhaps at some
point the Queen will enter the attack we
can play a move like f5 open the F file
and get this guy into the the action
this guy should be able to find a nice
place coming back into the game so it is
a very interesting way to play but it
isn't a very popular variation okay so
we will be looking at c5 and d3 is a
very playable move spill Thompson's
favorite so for people that play Bill
Thompson in the audience you should
prepare for that but we're going to look
at d4 here which is the main move and
alright so this is the move we're going
to be looking at today it is still
possible to not play the Shakur and you
can play the curious variation and this
also is kind of interesting you might
get a slightly different pawn structure
than you would normally expect from a
roy lopez in such a position you can see
that black has conceded a little bit of
the center in an effort to get a lot of
activity and you'll notice the pawn
structure is very similar to the Benoni
so if you like to play those sorts of
pawn structures you know this might be
for you and black might at some point
get a lot of activity with his Knights
and this Bishop might find its way onto
this diagonal and okay White's hoping
alright I'm going to push in the center
at some point and so you get a very
interesting game so that's also a
possible option for black that you might
want to investigate on your own if
you're interested in playing this way
okay but we're looking at Queen to c7
tonight and the main move here is 9 to
d2 and who can tell me where that Knight
is headed if he gets a couple more turns
because there's a very famous Roy Lopez
maneuver with the Knights yeah
right yeah so he's going to go to f1 and
he's going to jump either to III or g3
and ultimately he's going to try to land
on f5 so white is thinking usually about
a King side attack in these lines so if
you get a Knight to f5 you're usually
doing pretty good
so that's if he gets a couple more turns
that's where he's headed
alright black usually will do something
now in the center to kind of stop some
counter play that he has he'll take and
he'll go back putting pressure on the
center and white wants to be careful
whenever he plays d5 sometimes black can
get a lot of activity pretty easily for
example here we can attack the bishop
and if you save your Bishop we're going
to reroute the knight to c5 where both
of these Knights will be looking pretty
good for example after some normal
continuation black has a lot of activity
so he's gotten some counter play and
this is what happens when they play d5
it's it's very typical but you just want
to make sure you understand when you do
play d5 that okay black might end up
getting a lot of counter play which is
why normally in this position they keep
the tension white will put his knight on
B 3 and what black does have a plan here
he's going to go dislodge the knight but
White has just enough time to get this
move in and okay now the D pawn is
sufficiently defended and we'll get to
our starting position in just a couple
moves here
the bishop stays on this diagonal where
it still has control over f5 and the
rule comes into the game and okay so the
Queen moves over and this is sort of the
starting variation for tonight's lesson
so if you're playing in the tournament
it looks like we got a pretty good
showing tonight maybe yeah this will be
the starting position so we'll go ahead
and we'll check out a couple games now
all right so this first game is a game
between Alexander galosh Karpov and
Alexei Scheer of and I thought this was
a quite a nice game played by black here
and we'll get right to it and we'll look
at it from blacks point of view this
time okay so we'll get back to our
position and okay in this position so we
know d6 is the main move here in a
second here but okay he castles so
instead of playing
six he castles which does allow a
Marshall gambit
so black can sometimes sacrifice the
pond with d5 which is why white players
often avoid this not playing the move c3
but okay they might play a move sorry
like a4 or h3 and play will be a lot
different but in this game his opponent
allows the marshal but shear off was
just joking he played d6 it's worth
looking into this line because it's very
aggressive stuff so what does this
aren't you you're losing upon here after
the capture you get to pick up the e pod
alright so this is a very famous
position that okay LeMond Aronian is the
big proponent of this now you'll see at
the top level they're still kind of
arguing over whether this is playable or
not most games end up being a draw on
this line even though it gets really
sharp right away and if you're
unfamiliar with this position you can
get crushed pretty quickly and there was
a game between kappa blanka and marshall
and it said that marshall prepared this
position for like 10 years before he
played it against kappa blanka and when
he finally played it he still lost kappa
blanka was good and he in that game he
played Knight to f6 and over time the
moves Knight to f6 and Bishop to b7 have
kind of gone away and the popular trend
now is c6 we will go too much into it
but okay that protects the knight and
what's going on why why did we go down
upon here how are we going to get our
attack going well we're going to get
this guy into the game and quickly a lot
of pieces can get here into the attack
so we'll attack the rook and when it
goes back Queen to h4 this pretty much
you have to play g3 if you play h3 we
are going to sacrifice and it should
work so we'll take this and this should
be a terminal position blacks should be
able to win here and it's funny whatever
computer we have here I was analyzing
with Dany Machuca who's not here so we
can talk about them and it said either
this move had to be played or f4 but
then I went home and I asked stock fish
in it f4 and it just started laughing at
me
it's like it announced mate and it's
like this is terrible
and then it wouldn't tell me the line so
I don't even know it it's lad you can't
play it for okay but if you have to play
this move then you can see something's
kind of gone wrong and blacks going to
bring his rooks in and it should be a
losing position okay so not h3 but g3
and here's the main move you can see
black is going to start to get a lot of
activity here kind of quickly the other
rooks coming in occasionally you play fi
of f4 so it's pretty dangerous for white
and so the thing is white has to play a
lot of good defense so these are kind of
really interesting positions to study if
you want to do so on your own because it
teaches you how to mix defense with the
initiative so I really recommend that if
you're interested you take a look at
these positions and I'll just show the
main line which is definitely not the
only way that this position can be
played but just to show the basic scheme
the queen is nicely placed where she can
always go back if need be and sometimes
if there's a rook that ends up over here
the knight will be able to go back and
defend the h2 square so of course not
the only way to play and the bishop is
going to come back to f5 and you get a
position like this where White has
survived the attack but black still has
a bunch of pressure for the pawn and
normally it's you know a very
interesting game there's always some
crazy stuff that might happen a lot of
different things could happen in between
this line and what you might see in the
game but it seems like to be a pretty
equal and balanced game based on the
most recent Grandmaster practice okay we
will return yeah so in the game his
opponent allowed the marshal and he's
playing a Lexie sheriff who's known for
really aggressive style and a very
tactical person but he decided to enter
in the closed Roy Lopez here okay so we
prevent Bishop to g4 and we go after the
Bishop c5 all right
d3 of course is playable we're looking
at this move tonight and after we get
back to our position we kick the knight
around
we'll look at this position here now the
most common move was played and that's
Queen to e2 one of the reasons is he's
going to do something with this guy this
guy is going to have to go somewhere to
get off at the C file so the rooks can
use the file and in this game
his opponent tried to go to d3 and all
right rook to e8 makes a little bit of
sense sometimes if it might be black
that might be able to take here
sometimes it's white that will end up
taking here but it's important to have a
root on the e-file to kind of protect
the e5 square which we've talked about
is one of the main sources for white to
get his counter play and okay this
bishop is either going to go back just
to be out of the way or the bishops
going to come over and try to trade
itself for its counterpart that's a
little bit more active because all right
the bishop might not be doing something
especially in lines where they play d5
the bishop might want to go change
itself so he's not stuck behind all
these pawns okay so this is kind of his
point so now you got to protect your
pawn and in lines like these black is
always thinking about getting some
counter play like this so if it's his
turn again he might go to b4 and that's
why white decided to play the move a3
and it's interesting normally white will
do something on the Queen side either
he's going to play a3 and protect his
dark squares or he'll end up playing b3
which we'll see in the next game and b3
scores a lot better when you in these
positions you're playing lines with b3
because usually it's you know the night
that you're trying to keep out as some
of these squares so just from you know
personal experience and games that I've
seen ok lines with a3 don't always work
out well for the first player but all
right here he takes so now it's black
that decides to do something in the
center and he has taken on an isolated
deep on so in the future this could be a
weakness but he's hoping that he'll get
a lot more activity than his opponent
you know his Knights are now springing
to good squares and there is a little
bit of congestion in the white camp you
know this Knight still hasn't gotten out
of there what's going to happen okay so
the bishop was attacked
so it
retreated before he's trying to get some
activity over on the queenside
and now and bad move was already played
so this next move was very dubious
positionally he takes and now black gets
lots of pressure on the B file and he
continued with some rather strange play
somehow he should be trying to sacrifice
his beep on and get some activity with
his pieces this is something that
happens all the time in these lines one
one of the players is not always white
but white or black sometimes sacrifices
upon to get more activity and sometimes
that ends up being the case that he ends
up with a good enough position that he
can sack upon but uh okay rook to c2 was
played very strange and he is in a
little bit of trouble okay maybe he's
hoping well if I just get a few more
turns I can who I fish up here maybe I
can you know head towards f5 sometimes
up like g4 and then reroute my knight in
here but black has the move and he has a
chance to do something really powerful
here so it would be interesting to ask
because I've asked a couple people this
week about this position and what they
would play and it's not going to shatter
your brains with you know what he played
it's not going to be like wow that's the
greatest thing I've ever seen it's kind
of a simple move but I would be
interesting to see if the audience can
figure out what black played here he has
one move to give him a big advantage
and the camera is going to die at some
point so we got to be quick yes
okay this is the the second most common
way and black probably has a very tiny
advantage in this line so this move and
the move that was actually played are
the two best moves but there's an even
stronger move yeah okay so you're going
to go back okay so yes I can either take
I can just move my knight it'll be funny
if we repeated that be the funny way to
play yeah
the knight on c6 if it's yeah it's you
know whites turn that's why I'm always
dancing around yeah some of the whites
turn is hanging
okay well we'll give you the solution
here so you can pause your video at home
if you haven't figured it out yet but uh
Lexie sure off you decided d5 okay just
a good strong move he's getting rid of
his weakness and if white takes he's
going to bring the knight to a really
good square so he didn't take it he
decided he'd play f4 black were treated
a very innocent looking move but Sharov
is a tricky guy so there are some some
sneaky tactics that are going to come up
very shortly here white play d5 and now
a rather beautiful move was played here
we'll see if a the audience can work it
out so again you might want to pause
your video see if you can figure this
one out what did black do here it is a
tactic awesome Knight takes f4 which is
hoping to remove the defender now he
didn't end up taking it he just moved
his Queen if you take the point is we're
taking this night with check what are
you going to do if you block this way
there's a there's a lot of things that
we can do what's kind of cool is you can
even ignore what's going on because
if you take this you might run into some
trouble in certain lines here okay
because if you take with the Queen then
your rook would be hanging if you don't
take with your queen then your queen is
hanging so some interesting stuff can
happen you can also trade and after
either way you can again trade or not
trade and you can even there's some of
like clever moves here that your
computer will find perhaps Bishop to d8
with the idea of if you take and playing
here so there's a lot of clever little
tactics that might be going on in this
position and his opponent decided all
right I'm not going to take it I don't
want to give you my bishop and allow
some of those complications okay he went
back and now what's going on you have
two pieces hanging so how can that be
good so black
said okay I'll play here and the
tempting move the first move you you may
consider is g4 but this move actually
loses so black had to figure all of this
complicated stuff out you know before he
went in for this line because obviously
we can't just like move our knight and
then we'll end up losing a piece so he
has to play a bishop move what's funny
is if you ask your computer every legal
bishop move wins it doesn't matter what
you do they all win and my computer
couldn't figure it out I like to think
about this position for like an hour
last night he's like just every Bishop
move is the same they just all wait
it couldn't figure it out okay but
perhaps the most testing and objectively
the best move is a Bishop to h4 where
after you take how we throw in this
check wherever you go we grab this and
there's there's some problems here for
you if you just take the bishop for
example this move is actually quite
strong you're threatening not only to
take this pawn but you're also
threatening to take this Knight and
exploit the pin here so there's quite a
lot of threats so the best move actually
is rook to c7 and okay check a very
interesting move removing the defender
and okay you get a position like this
where you can't take the bishop still
because I'm taking here and then
okay here looks pretty strong so you
have to be pretty pretty careful here so
this is a lot to to work out in your
head also possible and more
aesthetically pleasing is the move
Bishop to d6 after which you were used
to be hanging to pieces but now you're
hanging three so quite clever ah all
right so we should take this if we take
here the point is rook takes Bishop and
you're in you're in a little bit of
trouble here we can even just simplify
and get some material back after a
position like this and black is much
better he has more material and his
pawns have a these pawns are looking
pretty good so you got to be careful
with those guys alright so what do you
really should play in this position is
to take this Knight and again it's it's
some very complicated stuff and there
are a lot of cute lines but I'll just
show one line normally whenever he gets
to take this on then he's doing really
well because the rooks gonna make a lot
of threats soon so here he just cleans
it up and this is still quite a messy
position so it would have been
interesting to know what exactly sure
I've intended to play head g4 shown up
on the board also strong you know it's
fun to play around with all these other
moves on your computer so it's
interesting I don't know which one he
would have played and they're all so
complicated and you didn't get some
messy position it so we'll never know
what he would have played but his
opponent wisely did not go in for that
and play it instead rope to c7 so you
can again you can you can play like the
young gentleman in the front of the room
this is the second best move but he's a
tricky guy so he played another really
tricky move here and it was at least to
some complications
he played Bishop to c5 okay you don't
have to take that bishop but he decided
to take it and what's going on now looks
like this night is about to make any
discovery at once so I share off
blundered is there some really good
night discovery well he went in for one
okay this is a good move right the queen
is attacked it looks like you're going
to just go
pick up this night things are going to
be fine for you but it's actually not
that easy he moves his queen around you
can consider the desperado but what's
more important here is time because in
the end of this line he's going to want
to be able to pick up the beep on and
we'll see why that's so important in the
game continuation so Knight to e6 the
Queen moves over and now a lot of
material is going to come off the board
and then we're going to understand
what's going on all right so the knight
was taken Queens are traded and you can
take back either way he took with the
night just so that okay the rook is on
the same file as its pawn here your
knight is hanging so you make some
trades and in the end of it you get to
pick up this beep on and this endgame is
winning for black the problem for white
of course is this pawn it's going to do
this and then you lose so white right is
best but it's it's over now it's just a
technical task for the Grandmaster here
a Bishop to e6 a nice safe square and
it's kind of nice that your Bishop is on
one of the squares that the pawn needs
to go to and there's really just not a
whole lot that you can do and not quite
like what he did here because you can
just play this move and this will just
win but he played even more accurately
which is something that I try to get all
my students to do just because you're
you're winning you still want to play
the most accurate moves if for no other
reason that your game will be more
aesthetically pleasing and you should
all be chess artists and play the best
move in every position and here we
played a really nice move rook to b4 and
it highlights the fact that this guy is
kind of trapped he's not going back this
way and okay if you go to g5 for example
your Bishop is trapped because this rook
is is right here and if you go back to
either square rack here then this move
is going to cause you some headaches
you can defend this but now I'm going to
push and I'm threatening to take this
and then make a queen so very nice move
it I provoked the move G and only now
does he go to the 3rd rank and cause
some some problems here okay so the
bishop went back and black got his last
piece into the game there's and then
even here he play
the most accurate move okay there's a
lot of rook moves that are going to win
here but I like this one because you're
going to see in just a minute if the
knight ever goes to d1 you can just
snatch it up and take this guy over here
and after this move he gave it up so
yeah very interesting display of tactics
and that's what happens too often in the
roy Lopez it's a positional battle and
then suddenly when tactical things
happens they can get wild and crazy so
it's not just a boring opening from
start to finish all right we'll have a
look at one more game here and okay this
time we'll take a look at it from
White's perspective here and this is the
game between two polivanov on Chuck from
the amber rapid in 2011 so it was a
rapid game so they were moving pretty
quickly but we'll take a look at it all
right we'll get back to our position
here all right are you familiar with
this guy walking in the room now do you
play the brayer is that your thing no I
thought that's what you play what do you
play oh okay um all right so here's our
position and we saw Queenie two in the
last game here white tries to do
something a little bit different he goes
back and it's worth mentioning - one
more thing about this line but only if I
can remember let's see there are some
lines
what really boring things happen
sometimes in these lines let's see let's
just put this guy here in here I didn't
mention it in the other video but
sometimes white just like gives up and
like basically forces a draw here you
can capture everything and like trade
these guys and then you can either take
or you cannot take and they get to this
really boring position and okay most of
these games I've always been draws Anna
Cobian has been on the black side here
and he played a couple of moves and then
it was a draw so you can be really
boring if you want as white if you want
to draw because you guys are pretty
grandmaster lee in the audience you
you need your drawers that's the way to
do it but okay so we'll go back and
instead we'll look at a bishop to be won
and he'll use a little bit of a
different strategy in this game you'll
see at the moment the night goes to a
five black is going to play the move b3
which is what we kind of talked about so
instead of a three this time he's going
to defend his light squares on the Queen
side and in my personal opinion this is
one of the better ways to play so all
right we see this maneuver again right
he's trying to get rid of the bishop
trapped behind the ponds which is what
he's going to look to do whenever white
plays the move d5 and here Bishop to d3
sort of a tricky move his point is he's
going to play before the nights going to
have to jump into c4 and he'll take the
knight forcing an isolated pawn and
black doesn't have to allow this he
could say take this and just play before
himself and then the variation that
happens in the game won't have happened
but he decides to allow it which okay
fair enough
b4 so the big question in this position
it might look like okay you're just
losing a pond but uh you can't grab the
pond right now and we'll we'll try to
understand why black actually has a way
to regain the pond here after taking the
rook forcing the Rupe to go back he can
get rid of all of the bishops and his
queen will be able to take back on
before so we'll take everything and
we'll take it back and then if anything
it's black that's better here but it's
not by much
so that's why he didn't just grab this
pawn so you're not winning upon and the
big question here is okay are we going
to be able to win this pawn or is this
going to be a strong annoying passed
pawn and okay in the game it turned out
it was a more of a weakness than a
strength
so here a3 yeah he realized he didn't
want to go he didn't want to lose his
beep on now he is threatening to take
the pawn so it was defended and now he's
going to slowly build pressure on the C
pawn so we can imagine
this is kind of fun for white no easel
I'm just going to build the pressure and
have the more active pieces so alright
the night is coming into f4 you gave
away the dark squared bishop s' so okay
we want to be looking at the f4 square
alright and he slowly builds and here it
comes
alright and then at some moment you know
we're going to move the Queen perhaps
we're going to put our knight on D 2 and
we're going to just put a lot of
pressure on this pawn it hasn't turned
out to be a hindrance to the white
player at all but okay f6 so Danny
showed up so we had to play f6 you like
it alright as usual it's not the best
move but arias um it's some legal move
and at one point he jumped in so at the
proper moment we get to keep that night
out so is that night doing something in
here is it is it bothering white or will
there ever be a tactical opportunity to
take the knight and then take one of the
rooks that's not protected who knows
okay now the problem for black is he's
so tied up on the Queen side that white
can actually launch a surprisingly
effective attack on the King side he's
using two nights in a queen and you
don't have a lot of defenders over there
here worked out really well for him okay
so he defended his pawn and alright this
is not not very easy for him what should
he do and here he played sort of an
interesting move he is allowing a
sacrifice here he's giving up a pawn
with check what could he be thinking
well now the knight is trapped so white
is committed to sacrificing but good
thing he's winning so this is a good
sacrifice and yeah the King is just
really naked on the Kings side over here
there's not a lot that he can do
yeah brought a bishop back and in this
position he resigned
so yeah this move is coming which is
pretty strong and the problem is if you
defend against it well now there are
some tactical liabilities with this
Knight so we can check per se and then
take this
and okay you're losing a piece and
you're playing a grandmaster
and all right so that's why yeah he
resigned there so yes that's a little
bit about the rule Oh PES and how you
should play with it as both colors there
would be interesting we've done efore
quite extensively in the past few weeks
here so be nice to get some D for
openings maybe or something a little
more offbeat and a lot of you have been
saying the openings I pick are too good
you know it's the main line everything
you guys want like a nonsense episode
so perhaps reluctantly I'll have to you
know bring the box back and we'll do an
episode with just all bad openings and
Danny will be happy people at home will
be happy and I'll be crying the whole
time because I'll be so upset that I
have to do it but I once in every 20
episodes we got to do something nonsense
so send in your submissions for that and
as always please like share subscribe
and a big shout out to logic and
morality I just figured out what read it
was the other day and he posted my thing
that was pretty cool
so keep doing that my fans have been
doing a pretty good job sharing me
around and I'll see you guys next week